[Music]
pleasure to share today some research
looking at the relationship between
technical and legal approaches to
privacy and some approaches to bridging
the gaps between them I should note that
the work that I'm talking about today is
the result of an interdisciplinary
collaboration between computer
scientists legal and policy experts and
social scientists and information
scientists across Harvard MIT in
Georgetown among other collaborators the
motivation of our work stems from the
inadequacy of current privacy frameworks
and the practices that result from them
in particular we've observed that the
current regulatory framework is
ill-suited to protect privacy in the
digital age we see that regulatory
requirements are ambiguous and open to
interpretation it's often difficult if
not impossible to understand what
they're designed to protect this is
particularly true as technological
developments challenge traditional
understandings of privacy practical
approaches may require time-consuming
case-by-case review and negotiation and
this often results in markedly different
treatment where the same or similar data
sets held by different organizations are
treated markedly differently
we also see that underlying privacy
concepts such as personally identifiable
information seem fundamentally unable to
keep up with the pace of technological
change regulatory frameworks seem to
endorse ad hoc approaches that failed to
provide adequate protection we see this
for example in the HIPAA Privacy Rule
safe harbor which requires the redaction
of identifiers from a list of 18 and we
now know that this does not provide
adequate privacy protection in practice
this is based on a faulty understanding
of privacy being a privacy protection
being related to the the redaction of
identifiers or being related to the
presence of PII when the regulatory
framework recognizes only a limited set
of privacy failures such as record
linkage being a primary mode of attack
that regulations are designed to prevent
and as a result
regulatory standards require frequent
amendment because they're based on
concepts that are ill-defined
and one of the main weaknesses of the
regulatory framework stems from privacy
concepts that are not very well defined
one of the main problems is the lack of
generality in these definitions legal
standards typically do not establish a
general privacy goal to be achieved
rather they specify a technique to be
used such as the redaction of
identifiers and this results in
determinations need to be based on a
case-by-case contextual analysis we also
see that these privacy concepts are not
very precise definitions of the
identification and anonymization are
often tautological so personally
identifiable information is defined as
information that identifies a person or
they may even set forth a standard
that's impossible to meet such as a data
provider must ensure that there is no
risk of reaiiy denta fication in
addition the satisfaction of a legal
standard cannot be demonstrated with
certainty it's often not clear that the
standard has been met when it's based on
a notion of reasonableness
and what we have learned from these many
observations is that privacy has a
hybrid nature it it involves both legal
and technical aspects the privacy
regulations often rely on concepts that
have both technical and legal meaning we
see that the reliance on concepts such
as identifiability distinguishability
link ability inference risk and others
inherently have both technical and legal
interpretations these concepts play a
central role in regulatory standards and
criteria in order to comply with a
privacy regulation you often have to
demonstrate that that the risk of
identifiability is very small or that
the risk of link ability is very small
but these concepts also have technical
interpretations they appear in the
statistical disclosure limitation
literature for example where definitions
and approaches for achieving privacy
protection in accordance with these
concepts are provided but at the same
time the legal and technical
understandings of privacy are often not
in harmony this is particularly true
when comparing new formal privacy models
like differential privacy to legal
approaches to protecting privacy you
start to see how this this dual nature
of privacy having legal and technical
components posing challenges when you
need to reconcile their relationship to
emerging concepts
we've seen a number of gaps between
technical and legal or normative
concepts of privacy one of these gaps is
in the generality of protection that's
provided regulatory requirements vary
according to industry sector
jurisdiction institution types of
information and other contextual factors
if you take the education privacy law in
the United States FERPA which protects
only certain information from education
records maintained by educational
agencies and institutions particularly
non-directory personally identifiable
information it's a small subset of
information that could be used in
privacy attack and if you've compared
this to something like differential
privacy you see that it's it's very
limited in the protection that it
affords we now know that in practice
privacy risks are not limited to the
information categories and contexts
contemplated by regulations we know that
analysts may combine information from
different contexts and formal privacy
models like differential privacy
recognize this they could be applied
wherever statistical or machine learning
analysis is performed regardless of the
context and protect all information
that's specific to an individual not a
limited subset identified in a
regulation
we also see gaps in this scope of
attacks that are contemplated by
regulations versus form of privacy
models regulations often contemplate a
limited set of specific attacks and
failures an examples record linkage
which can be understood as the reai dent
ocation of one or more records and
identify data set by uniquely linking
those records with identified records in
a publicly available debt data set in
some privacy regulations this is
identified as that the primary or sole
mode of privacy failure and they're
designed to ensure that the risk of a
record linkage to known auxilary data
sources is low but it ignores other
types of privacy failures but this
creates challenges when other privacy
attacks are identified over time
some examples are confirming an
individual's presence in a data set or
singling out an individual in the data
set even if not fully identified or
inferring information specific to an
individual with less than absolute
certainty
these are modes of privacy failure that
are arguably not recognized by certain
regulatory standards however formal
privacy models like differential privacy
recognized the importance of protecting
against these types of privacy attacks
and they're designed to provide
protection against a wide collection of
privacy attacks including those that are
not currently known
we also see gaps in the expectations
versus the scientific understanding of
privacy regulations that rely on the
concept of D identification or
anonymization are often not in agreement
with the current scientific
understanding of privacy the regulations
may be limited in scope they may not
provide an adequate level of privacy and
practice and they may not withstand
rigorous formal mathematical scrutiny an
example this is the HIPAA Privacy Rule
safe harbor method which is redaction of
certain identifiers which we now know
does not provide strong privacy
protection and practice reaction of
identifiers can fail to protect privacy
especially when applied to detailed
information and such as medical records
we now understand that any information
even information not traditionally
considered identifying has the potential
to leak information specific to
individuals
we also see gaps in the expectations
versus the privacy the scientific
understanding of privacy in certain
statutes which may be interpreted to
require something that's not technically
feasible such as absolute privacy
protection when sharing personal data
you could take title 13 of the u.s. code
as an example protects the
confidentiality of respondent
information protected by the US Census
Bureau and prohibits any publication
whereby the data furnished by an
individual can be identified and if you
were to interpret this language very
conservatively you could read title 13
to disallow any leakage of information
about individuals and therefore disallow
the publication of large amounts of
statistics
we also see that this binary view of
privacy found in title 13 whereby
information is either identifiable or
not is common to many regulations and
there's some known problems with this
approach information can never be made
completely non identifiable this
approach also fails to recognize that
privacy loss accumulates with successive
releases of information about the same
individuals and it can eventually lead
to a significant disclosure of personal
information in contrast formal privacy
models bound the privacy leakage of each
release and bound the total privacy
leakage across multiple releases
we also see that normative concepts are
often in stable over time whereas
technical concepts are based on on
stable definitions the notions of
privacy embedded in regulations are
continually evolving an example is
guidance from the Office of Management
and Budget budget to government agencies
responding to data breaches of federal
records this guidance has been updated
over time to address new ways that
de-identified data may be vulnerable to
potential attacks the latest guidance in
2017 advises that information that is
considered non personally identifiable
information may become personally
identifiable information in the future
as new data sources become available
and as we see that hardwired techniques
like the HIPAA safe harbor are shown to
be inadequate to protect privacy it's
unclear how to satisfy regulatory
standards like that one once they become
out of step with best practice and in
contrast differential privacy is the
subject of ongoing scientific research
and regardless of implementation there's
a strong assurance that it provides a
sufficient level of privacy in a wide
variety of settings we also see gaps in
the relationship to normative
expectations repairing that the
protection afforded by a particular
privacy technology to a normative
standard must be done with care for
example it may be difficult to make a
sufficiency claim with respect to
differential privacy and regulatory
requirements some examples of this we
see with formal privacy models which may
be considered privacy first definitions
prioritize privacy whereas real world
uses of data may demand making a
compromise between privacy and accuracy
and there may be some cases where the
regulations express requirements that
can be interpreted to exceed the
protection provided by formal privacy
models we may see this in the case of
title 13 especially with respect to
protections for establishments the
statements that privacy models are
privacy first in my book there are with
privacy only the only talk about privacy
try to capture utility it's done by some
other definition some other
I think there may be others in the room
who are better suited to answer this
question but I think that in in the
privacy parameter epsilon there's the
the balancing of privacy versus utility
but of course it provides very robust
privacy protection as the primary goal
others want to weigh in
but if in your Lister was only parts
first well I was referring to its
comment and saying yeah it's true that
they now will give a different answer
it's true it's true that the definition
is focuses on France and I think that
this is exactly mental I mean when you
look at a legal text you have to read
the text times under was presenting a
bunch of definitions from I think FERPA
and maybe the gramm-leach-bliley they
didn't remember but about like you know
definitions of personally identifiable
information and those definitions you
have to read as political decisions to
maintain certain kinds of utility right
and so the laws do speak to both privacy
and utility it's just that they assume
utility and then try to extract privacy
but wait a minute
right so they do speak to both those
things the words might have like if you
look at the legislative history for
example you can
all the debates about what sort of
utility wanted to be maintained but I
think talks this morning by telling them
then the paper is because billion
I think talks this morning by Jonathan
tipper the varix was explicit about
achieving privacy while also releasing
some invariants basically for free
because the option so I think it's I
wouldn't characterize privacy models as
being rigid there are like able to
accommodate multiple objectives like
privacy am facility in different orders
okay so from what I gather there have
been many many losses in regard to the
census as any of them ever touched upon
the subject of privacy the court
interpretation of it somehow it comes
more the court interpretation of the law
so is there ever been anyone sued the
breaches discussion I am not aware of
any lawsuits related to privacy breaches
the Supreme Court case that's most
closely related to these topics is
Baldridge versus Shapiro which involved
challenges to the redistricting data and
the need to obtain the raw data from the
Census Bureau in order to verify those
data tabulations and in in that case the
Supreme Court held that title 13 poses
an absolute bar to the release of raw
data to third parties confidentiality
protections are very strong
but some sort of lawsuit against the
census factor after the 9/11 when they
were homeland security was looking at
the various pockets of ethnic groups or
was that never taken part anyway there
are lots of breaches but they're
probably not public
so we have released several analyses
breaches by government agencies they
generally have been involved wartime or
national security
it's superseding of whatever privacy
regulation was in place well I'm not
aware of any such breaches census tunnel
fifteen minutes passed in 54 and both
the Patriot Act and the cyber security
acts up to 2015 specifically left the
protections in tunnel 13 in place the
2015 cybersecurity act explicitly said
that contravened all existing statute
superseded as their home sorry all
existing statutes um that does involve
some authorized building scrutiny of
confidential title 13 data in principle
but in fact that authorization would
require our private transport layer
security keys which have not been
requested and have not been surrendered
so the power Homeland Security has said
that publicly that's as far as I know
that's the cards do
so in our work we've aimed to come up
with a variety of different approaches
to writing privacy protection in
practice or in theory and overcoming
some of these gaps in in in the
different concepts we see in the legal
and technical literature the first
approach that we've pursued is to
develop a framework for privacy aware
data releases this framework is based on
modern concepts of privacy from the
theoretical computer science literature
and it's also modeled on information
security and information lifecycle
frameworks involves three steps the
first is developing a catalog of privacy
controls the second is identifying
information uses threats and
vulnerabilities in a particular use case
and then designing data releases by
aligning the uses and risks in a given
use case with appropriate controls and
doing so at each stage of the
information lifecycle so we developed an
example catalog of privacy controls
looking at procedural economic
educational legal and technical controls
at each stage of the information
lifecycle from collection through access
release and long-term use in storage and
we've developed a guide to selecting
appropriate privacy controls and this is
an example where you can look at the
identifiability
of the data after it's been transformed
in some way so we see that there are
some points given for illustration here
there may be direct or indirect
identifiers present or the direct and
indirect tie
fires may have been removed or there may
have been heuristic techniques applied
or there may have been rigorous SDL
techniques applied such as differential
privacy and along the other access
access you see the level of expected
harm from negligible to life-threatening
and in the regions you see the different
sorts of procedural and and technical
controls that would be appropriate given
the identifiability
and the level of expected harm ranging
from no additional controls to the
strongest controls secure data enclaves
and immutable audit logs and you see
that this differs from current practice
in some settings if you take the HIPAA
safe harbor has an example where direct
and indirect identifiers may have been
removed this framework would still
recommend that notice consent in terms
of service or even formal application
and oversight or data use agreement or
secure data Enclave and immutable audit
logs may be appropriate if the level of
expected harm is high
and we also recommend using a tiered
access model because this is a way to
finally tune the level of protection to
the intended uses of the data and the
level of protection required so for
examples some data sets may be made
available through open query access
using differentially private tools other
data sets may be made available for
download either with sanitation or
through a review and approval process
and the most sensitive data may be
protected via secure data Enclave and
only certain types of of monitored data
uses are permitted and this tiered
access model is inspired by the Harvard
privacy tools project model where data
may be made available through different
modes of access either through download
under the terms of the data use
agreement or statistics may be made
available to the public through a
differentially private mechanism
and one of the the questions that arose
in the development of the differential
privacy tools in this project was how do
you ensure are you sure the users of the
differentially private tools that
differential privacy is sufficient to
satisfy a data provider data providers
obligations under the law and so another
approach that we've pursued is bridging
legal and technical approaches to
privacy by formally modeling legal
requirements we've seen that that the
languages of computer science and
regulation are very different are there
ways to overcome some of these gaps and
one approach that we've looked at has
the goal of rigorously arguing that a
technological privacy solution satisfies
the requirements of a particular law
this approach involves extracting a
formal mathematical requirement from the
law and proving mathematically that a
technological privacy solution satisfies
the requirement that was derived from
the law as an example we modeled FERPA
the Family Educational Rights and
Privacy Act and we used a game based
privacy definition to extract a formal
model of the privacy desiderata for this
regulation and the goal in developing
this game based privacy definition was
to provide a concise and fairly
intuitive abstraction of purpose
requirements and then to show that if
differential privacy or another formal
privacy model satisfies the definition
and we know that we have a strong
argument that it satisfies the
requirements of FERPA I can walk through
some of the
steps developing this model of FERPA the
first step was to model the adversary
and we looked at the definition of
personally identifiable information
within phurba which includes this
language information that alone or in
combination is linked or linkable to a
specific student that would allow a
reasonable person in the school
community who does not have personal
knowledge of the relevant circumstances
to identify the student with reasonable
certainty we looked especially at that
language highlighted in green here and
took that to be FERPA simplicity
adversary we also modeled directory
information as defined by FERPA this is
language that's interpreted very
conservatively we erred towards what
interpretation is most beneficial for
the adversary this is because the
definition of directory information
found in FERPA is ambiguous and if we
were to make assumptions about the
definition new interpretations of
directory information could call the
assumptions we made into question so
instead we let the attacker choose what
constitutes directory information and
this makes the attacker very strong it's
a very conservative interpretation of
the law and here is a simplified version
of the FERPA privacy gain whereby the
adversary is given the directory
information and the computation is given
the directory information and the non
directory personally identifiable
information the protected information
the computation returns a result the
adversary takes the directory
information and the computation result
makes a guess of the private information
and wins the game if the guests of the
private information equals the private
information
and in attempting to generalize this
approach we started to look at different
concepts that appear in various privacy
regulations like personally identifiable
information link ability to see whether
it might be possible to interpret formal
privacy guarantees in a language of
these concepts
um so some common privacy concepts in
the law could Pai D identification
linkage imprints risk consent and opting
out purpose and access restrictions
these concepts are interpreted
differently across laws they also appear
in the technical literature often with
different definitions and
interpretations and those that appear in
the law we find that legal requirements
that are relevant to issues of privacy
and computation rely on an understanding
of a range of different privacy concepts
however none of the privacy concepts
that appear in the law refer directly to
differential privacy however the
differential privacy guarantee can be
interpreted in reference to these
concepts at the same time it can
accommodate differences in how these
concepts are defined across different
contexts
as an example I'll look at personally
identifiable information which is a
central concept appearing in privacy law
legal protections typically extend only
to PII information not considered
personally identifiable is not protected
you see this and in purpo and the HIPAA
Privacy Rule and other laws although the
definitions vary significantly they're
generally understood to refer to the
presence of pieces of information that
are linkable to the identity of an
individual or to an individual's
personal attributes should also note
that PII is is related to the concept of
Dia and a vacation which refers to a
collection of techniques that have
performed successfully are used to
remove PII or to transform PII into non
PII and we can interpret the
differential privacy guarantee in the
terms of this language we can do this
even though PII does not have a precise
technical meaning and in practice it may
be difficult to determine whether
information is personal identifying or
likely to be considered identifying in
the future another challenge here is
that the meaning of PII is typically
interpreted with respect to data
releases in a micro data or tabular
format but its meaning with respect to
statistical models or outputs of a
machine learning system is unclear
however when differential privacy is
used it can be understood as ensuring
that using an individual's data will not
reveal essentially any personally
identifiable information specific to her
regardless of the definition of PII that
is used this is an interpretation of the
differentially private guarantee using
the language that you see in laws and
regulations and this may be useful for
explaining differential privacy
and how it should be viewed with respect
to legal obligations to policymakers
and then a fourth approach that we've
been exploring is this idea of a hybrid
concept we recognize that privacy
concepts are near neither purely legal
nor purely technical they have an
inherent hybrid legal technical nature
and adopting an understanding of privacy
that is consistent across both its
technical and normative dimensions will
be critical to ensuring the personal
data are adequately safeguarded over the
long term however there are conceptual
gaps between the technical and normative
concepts that create challenges for
arriving at a universal notion of
privacy that's well understood within
both communities and literature's
understanding that the hybrid nature of
these concepts and developing tools for
implementing them will be necessary to
bridge the gaps between current legal
and technical understandings of privacy
an example of a concept that recognizes
the the legal or normative and technical
aspects of privacy is contextual
integrity
this is a framework that can be used
where it's possible to encode norms
formally and determine whether a
particular information flow respects
these norms for example where the norms
are unambiguous and effectively testable
however there may be other cases where
the normative concepts are not defined
explicitly or they may be defined
explicitly but they're not expressed in
a formal language that enables a precise
analysis and so more research is needed
to develop hybrid concepts that aim to
capture that the the dual technical
normative nature of privacy and some of
the work like the work to formally model
legal requirements exemplifies some work
in this direction and we're also looking
at ways to model privacy concepts
themselves like singling out this
approach involves identifying
fundamental privacy concepts used in
legal standards of privacy and the
statistical disclosure limitation
literature
examples include singling out link
ability and inference and for each
concept we perform a thorough legal
analysis and then construct a
mathematical model of the concept we
check whether the modeling agrees with
the legal analysis and then compare the
model with differential privacy for an
in-depth example this sort of analysis
with respect to singling out learning
Cohen will present on this on Wednesday
so you say identify the fundamental
concept used in labels
and I'm just wondering like it's a great
question
so we've been looking for concepts that
appear in multiple privacy regulations
and singling out is a good example of
this it is often given different names
like uniqueness or distinguished ability
or the ability to distinguish an
individual well starting with the rules
but then trying to identify the concept
of underlies the rule and just singling
out
and you do see the similar concepts
appearing again and again where you see
concepts of singling out appearing in
the GDP are but also in laws like HIPAA
or FERPA and in the related guidance
where they try to flush out what it
means to single out an individual or
distinguish an individual in a data set
so the idea here is is if you're able to
prove that that differential privacy is
is sufficient or a particular approach
to privacy is sufficient to protect
against singling out then you are able
to show arguably that that technique is
is sufficient to meet of a broad range
of different privacy standards under the
wall
and there may be opportunities for
future privacy regulations based on this
this hybrid concepts approach we argue
that that regulation should articulate
clear goals for privacy protection and
these goals should be consistent with
legal and technical understandings the
goal should be in line with the
scientific understanding of privacy they
should also be understood by legal and
policy experts regulation should move
away from implicitly or explicitly
endorsing ad hoc de-identification
techniques and an example of a
regulation that moves in this direction
is is the gdpr or more specifically some
guidance on European data protection law
that outlines goals that go beyond the
traditional notion of D identification
guidance that refers to protection from
singling out linking or inferring an
individual's personal data from a data
set provides more specificity than
concepts such as personally identifiable
information
however these concepts have not yet been
defined precisely and formally from a
mathematical perspective but they do
aim to describe a clear goal than
previous regulations and guidance and so
it's a step in the right direction if
you're interested in this work these
publications provide a much more
in-depth look at this research and I
welcome any questions
we rang the so we have time for one
quick question
and thus move on since there were
question during the talk maybe let's
balance again
[Applause]